so today we consider another case of
somebody getting canceled
uh after things they posted on the
internet a long time ago resurface
as always the term resurface is an
intentionally but dishonestly passive
way of phrasing and it makes it sound
like the thing was locked in a chest
under the sea and happened to lodge
itself loose
and you know bubble to the surface sort
of like in the movie the mask
for any aficionados of 90s jim carrey
films in any case the point is that this
is not a passive or accidental process
actual humans have to go looking for
this stuff and then they have to find it
they have to spread it around all for
the express purpose of destroying the
life
of another human and this time the
target was
american idol contestant caleb kennedy i
must admit that i
i never heard of caleb kennedy before
and honestly i didn't know that american
idol was still on the air i really
i thought it went off the air years ago
but apparently it is on the air
and caleb kennedy was on the air until
now the new york post has a story quote
american idol top five finalist caleb
kennedy has left the show after a video
surface showing him next to someone
wearing what appears to be a ku klux
klan hood
a representative for the show confirmed
to the post that kennedy will no longer
be moving forward in the competition
the singer 16 posted a statement about
his departure on instagram on wednesday
he said quote
hey y'all this is going to be a bit of a
surprise but i'm no longer going to be
on american idol
there was a video that surfaced on the
internet and it displays actions that
were not meant to be taken
in that way i was younger and did not
think about the actions but that's not
an excuse i want to say sorry to all my
fans and everyone who i've let down
i'll be taking a little time off social
media to better myself but saying that i
know this has hurt and disappointed a
lot of people and made less people lose
respect for me i'm so sorry i pray that
i can one day regain your trust in who i
am
and have your respect thank you for
supporting me now um
kennedy's mother has come out and
clarified that the video
doesn't depict a clan hood kennedy is
with a friend who's wearing a costume
inspired by a movie they've both seen
there was a movie called the stranger's
prey at night
and sure enough you can go look it up
you'll find if you do
that the main bad guy wears a white hood
and uh not a clan hood just a white
scary hood
and it also came out at around the time
that the video was taken
so the story seems to line up speaking
of which
caleb kennedy is currently 16 years old
that movie came out four years ago
the video was taken then when he was 12
12 years old
he had to leave the show because of a
video from when he was 12.
think about that for a moment if there's
going to be any controversy stemming
from that video it should really be that
his mom
shouldn't have let him watch a rated r
slasher film at the age of 12. but aside
from that
there's nothing here in fact let's
pretend for a moment that caleb really
was sitting next to a friend
who really was joking around and
pretending to wear a clan hood
he wasn't but what if he was so they
were 12. i repeat again 12 years old
it is the height of both absurdity and
cruelty to hold someone responsible
for a joke they made at the age of 12.
insult to injury in this case is that
very clearly the joke had nothing to do
with the kkk
caleb kennedy had not a thing to
apologize for he hasn't disappointed
anyone let anyone down
he hasn't hurt anyone's feelings and if
he hasn't anyone's feelings screw them
who cares
their feelings are irrelevant
i'm glad their feelings are i hope their
feelings are get are more hurt
it it is it is everyone else who owes
him an apology you know for doing this
to a kid for putting him in this
position
and normally my policy as you know is to
not defend any canceled person who
apologizes
but i make an exception here because
even now the kid is only 16.
i can no more hold him responsible for
mishandling a pr crisis at 16
that i can for a supposedly but not
really offensive joke he made it 12.
there there are things that that we
should hold kids accountable for things
like for example
carjacking and murdering someone as
those two teen girls in dc did
though the court system in that case is
just giving them a slap on the wrist yet
a sane society
would not hold kids accountable at all
in any serious or public way at least
for jokes they make or opinions they
express
we however are not a sane society or
maybe that's letting us off the hook
because i often times as a kind of
verbal shorthand we'll call things crazy
or insane
i feel like that's this is the most
common words you hear on this show
um but but really oftentimes the things
that i'm calling crazy or insane are
neither of those things
in reality much of this is considered
an intentional cruelty
for many in the cancel mob they get a
thrill out of tearing somebody down
and watching them crash and burn even a
kid
there are many in this country who are
failures in their own lives
and they're lonely and they're miserable
and they've achieved nothing of note
they have no talent they have no skills
they have no ambitions
they have no plans for the future they
do nothing with their life they sit
around watching tv and
on the internet that's all they do
staring at screens
they live pointless empty despairing
awful lives of their own making
they feel powerless and forgotten and
nearly non-existent because they
because they're losers and the world
doesn't pay attention to them and
shouldn't pay attention to them
because they have nothing interesting to
say or anything valuable to offer
and so for these miserable wretched
nothings
the only way that they can feel an
approximation of
joy is to destroy someone else's joy
the only way they can feel power is to
cut someone else down
a kid on american idol top five
living his dream achieving remarkable
things at the age of 16
hasn't hurt anybody and these people
hate him for it
and we're eager for any chance to cut
him down to size
personal really when the canceled mob
comes for you it's not because of you
it's because of them you're a blade of
grass that poked its head a little too
far above the rest and these
these other withered little blades down
in the dirt
want to make themselves feel taller by
bringing you down closer to them
that's what drives much of the canceled
culture envy misery resentment
a tale as old as time there's also
plenty of cowardice driving it too
institutions have to bend to the whims
of these
losers american idol could have easily
stuck by their guy told the mob to get
lost and say hey listen shut up he was a
kid
just stop but that would require that
would require
some tiny semblance of moral courage and
that's too much to ask for
and completing the picture there's also
ideology and politics feeding into it
caleb kennedy is a white male anytime a
white male can be painted as a racist
it's considered a win by the left
whether the white male actually is
racist is of course irrelevant
so all of these factors converge and
together they create the unholy
concoction
that we know as cancel culture and for
that reason
perhaps somewhat ironically all of those
involved
in this are certainly cancelled hey
listen
hit the subscribe button do it right now
i
demand it and i thank you for your
compliance it is somewhat
appreciated